well hello there Lauren gray from home
yes mom where are you were my chat with
you right now I am in my room in LA you
know like so many other people in Los
Angeles right now yeah this is why et's
doing this this is quarantine
confessionals so I appreciate you
sitting down with me because the last
time we chatted was a lot different than
this we were in the studio and now we're
all yeah exactly so how are you doing
where you cooped up how are you
surviving yeah I'm doing good actually I
feel like this is actually like a good
thing for me to be in and you know I had
to go grocery shopping which was a mess
obviously that was the only stressful
part for me but it's taken a lot of the
pressure off of going outside because I
feel like there's always pressure that I
have to go out and do things and there's
not know my house and everyone's on the
same way so that's been cool I know I
fully people are reacting and adapting
to this like new experience in different
ways but I'm with you I've learned that
I'm like oh we've kind of like stayed at
home like isolation can be good every
once awhile I just don't like when it's
like mandated on me for weeks yeah that
part's scary especially because it's
like it varies you know different people
say different things about how long it's
gonna be and that's the scary part and
also for me a lot of the part that that
I'm afraid of is the panic other
people's panic and it that's what
stresses me out about the whole
situation but staying at home isn't a
problem you know do you feel do you feel
like to kind of almost like a sense of
responsibility knowing just like your
reach and how many people follow you to
kind of show people no it's cool and
it's gonna be okay to stay at home get
creative do fun things stay busy yeah
definitely I mean I feel like this is
the perfect time for content creators is
everyone at home and you know you have a
lot of time to make videos I guess it's
a good time for that and I guess I do
feel kind of a responsibility to and
also to entertain because people are you
know bored right now and in their houses
and a lot of people can't see their
friends I know my
friends back home haven't been able to
see each other so and for a lot of
people that's a big part of you know
their life for me as well but I don't
have as many funds but now that you are
home by order of the mayor and you know
the governor do you feel any added
pressure to like create tic TOCs now
more than ever like more on a more
consistent basis if you like not so much
pressure but more I just feel like I
have more freedom too because you know
I'm home and there's not many other
things I can do with my time other than
you know work on music and make videos
so those things I can do for my house
and those are the things that I control
right now that's kind of the mindset
that I'm in is do what I can do do what
I can control and stay productive it can
I feel like it can get depressing really
fast like being home and not having
anything to do so I think being
productive is important and it's almost
a weird way to like stay connected to
people - including your own friends
right yeah definitely yeah um what
advice do you have cuz I mean I'm gonna
like I join tick tock before like I
think around the time I interviewed you
actually on et live and I joined
tick-tock but it wasn't until
self-quarantine where I really been like
actually playing with it honestly it's
been kind of doing wonders for my
tick-tock game so I want to know from
you like what advice you have for those
at home or joining for the first time
like what makes a good first tick tock I
feel like at least for the things that
are trending like pay attention to
what's trending see what other people
are making get inspired by other people
and also talk about things that are you
know happening currently I mean
everyone's in quarantine right now so
everyone's except where in the whole
world is pretty much experiencing the
same thing so I feel like it's a good
time to you know speak on those things
that everyone's experiencing and
everyone can relate to and also have fun
I made it everyone's in your house
everyone knows that everyone's in their
house or everyone's expecting that
content that's just like what's expected
so I just kind of do what everyone else
is doing but with your own twist
obviously but
everyone's going through the same thing
so I would also add be patient because I
will say my boyfriend and I it took us
two hours I'm not joking two hours to
learn renegade which to be fair came in
the land right like that's not so much
training as much as much as it was a
couple months ago but like we're like we
have the time to do it do it now you're
so high yeah there's so many dances I
mean it even takes me a while to learn
them sometimes yeah frustrating renegade
it took me and Brooke my my best friend
it took us like three hours to learn we
were sweating it's a really good workout
too you know why was i sweating girl I
was all over the place I was like I had
to take breaks intermissions time outs
what are you learning right now there's
a new one that I think it's made in the
stallion and it's I'm a savage yeah I
mean I forget how it goes but it's
really good I love it so you mentioned
that you're also working on music while
you're at home with that what has that
time looked like for you what do you
have in the works yeah so I I feel like
this whole situation can put a lot of
things on hold for a lot of people
luckily like right before the quarantine
and everything happened I learned how to
you know record my own vocals so all I
need is like a check and I can record
from there but because I want to keep
working obviously because I want to get
music out as soon as possible so that's
like my time frame is ASAP but I'm glad
that I got everything and learned before
like literally right before this all
happened
so that I can continue working and
that's another way that I'm spending my
time I love it sounds like it's been
like this time has been so productive
for you yeah I mean oh there was a lot
of rain in LA recently and it was kind
of a really weird vibe everything felt
really strange and I wasn't very
motivated if like the past two weeks you
know everything's kind of updating iris
and then with you know not having
supplies and happy to go shopping and
then also the weather was
helping it was very gloomy and buried so
for the last two weeks I was like I'm
out but I'm back in business now the
sun's out at least even in my house
there's still some natural light
happening so soon that's that's the pros
of everything and I feel like also being
in my house and it's kind of I have to
self-motivate mmm you know like I have
to be responsible and worried because
it's really easy to just sit back and
watch TV every day but it's important to
stay active as much as possible that's
something that I I'm thinking about a
lot is oh my gosh I need to like walk on
the treadmill err like who will lap
around my neighbourhood or something I'm
doing circuit workout like literally in
my living room like I have to be here
like it was a sick day you know you're
just like in your sweats all day
watching TV yeah and I don't want to
call it a lockdown because I know they
said it's not a lockdown but I think
it's called this stay at home or at home
yeah safer at home it ends on my
birthday on my 18th birthday
oh yeah so I'm coming out of I'm coming
out of quarantine and adult wow that's
kind of tributed think about actually
yeah it's really weird do you know how
you want to celebrate I have no idea I
can't really make any plans or anything
so my parents are gonna be able to come
by the time you know so I'm just kind of
seeing what happens but I'm not a big
celebration person I only need a big
party I just wanna hang so it's
hopefully you do celebrate it in some
fashion though cuz you only turn 18 once
you know we'll celebrate it we'll
celebrate it later I don't need it's me
on the day when everything I think yeah
more important so um you know another
way people are kind of passing the time
of course is besides the binging binge
watching stuff is listening to music and
can we please talk about how the
Pussycat Dolls put your song on their
spotify playlist
yeah I saw in my mentions and I was like
are you freaking out yeah I was really
excited I just made a I just made a
video to their new song and react
yeah and I love
I loved the video and everything so I
was really excited and you know I do see
candles but also they put you on a
playlist with like Nicki Minaj Beyonce
Rihanna like all these amazing artists
female artists yeah which was really
cool and I like definitely was not
expecting it and my team was like we
were gonna flag you but we see you
already time I know what's your story
nicely okay yes also I was a fire
playlist that PCD put together I just
gonna have some quick questions for you
just about like how you're surviving you
know social distancing and being at Paul
so first off what has been your go-to
like quarantine snack or food chips and
salsa right so many so many jars of
salsa in my pantry in my fridge and I I
just went to the store today and got
more chips because I'm going through
chips like crazy but it's hard it's hard
to find like you know it's hard to buy
produce because you know it goes bad so
I have a lot of like taquitos and peas
roll from freezer food no yume but just
what shows are you binging to pass the
time um recently I started Bates Motel
good yeah and I watch the office I've
watched the office for like I don't even
know how many years I watch it on repeat
I probably seen every episode at least
like a hundred times so keep watching
Bates Motel this is not a spoiler but
you're in for a treat because Rihanna
makes a guest spot in the last season
real I've been like the second middle of
the second season I wanna say like
beginning middle a second season right
now and I'm like it's like getting a
little bit slow but I feel like if I
push through it it's gonna be worth it
you have to yeah keep going what else
are you doing the past design um besides
working and making videos I mean
watching shows doing my best to stay
active cleaning my house cuz I live in
this house and it needs to be clean so I
gotta make sure my house is clean we
organize maybe a little bit spring clean
yeah
so I have CNN like news updates
yeah so every time there's a new update
I'm like on it I'm like the first person
to know cuz I get a notification so I
read a lot of news so basically just
normal stuff but just from the comfort
of my own home although I do miss going
to restaurants I'm miss California Pizza
Kitchen and I miss cutsie is so much and
my first places I'm going win this
absolutely although there's some
restaurants are still delivering so take
advantage of it it's gonna be our
weekend treat I can't wait okay so
what's your current live-in outfit like
what are you rocking around the house
these days
okay so I wear like sweatpants or might
go to usually gray sweatpants great
that's my favorite color
but I found these sweatpants at Topshop
and I wasn't able to find them for two
years so I wore the same pair of gray
sweatpants every pretty much every day
for two years they were disgusting and
gross but I did an interview and the
girl was like oh we found the link and I
was like send it to me because I am been
able to find them and I bought them in
every color so that's what I've been
wearing is different variations of the
same pants and just like different
shirts it's really hard to dress up and
look cute when you're not going anywhere
a little bit though you know like
getting up doing your hair maybe a
little like face B and putting on a nice
shirt that does help because you know
it's really easy to like fall into like
you said like this sick day feeling
where you just feel gross every day I
just don't want that to happen
okay so last question you're screaming
Bates Motel right now why first of all
like what made you get in a base it was
recommended to me and I just I I thought
it looked good and I like crime and all
that spooky stuff so yeah I was excited
about it and finally what's next on your
list to stream or binge watch oh boy I
don't know I wanted to do like a like a
movie marathon type I've never seen a
Harry Potter movies not one no no the
perfect time to do that yeah I've never
seen any of them and I all my friends
loved it but I've I've always been more
of like a I don't know like a lord of
the Rings type okay
in Star Wars I watch all those but I
never leave more Stallworth a Time Lord
reads but you got it you got a watch
Harry Potter it's a staple okay I'm
going I'm gonna do that because I have
plenty of times it's um I love it thank
you so much for spending the time with
us obviously keep doing what you're
doing because you really are providing a
lot of entertainment and some comfort
for a lot of people who follow you and
it's a blast and plus I need to learn
the next dance trend and challenge yes
it's Meghan the stallion you'll see it
if you go well I've done it like twice
I'm gonna I'm gonna learn it for you
this week okay keep an eye on my
tick-tock I will
alright thanks girl
[Music]